What historians, particularly economic historians,
talk about is this idea of the leading sector.
How do you think about this transformation?
How is it not just that smooth inevitable looking curve?
And the idea they use this idea of the leading sector.
That there's one particular area of the economy
that is so profitable... and so big
that it pulls everything else in its wake.
Bringing about new opportunities for growth.
New jobs. Wage growth. Everything.
And at first in the pre-industrial capitalism
of the 18th century you have cotton, sugar and shipping.
Then industrial capitalism: wheat, railroad, steel.
And then in the 20th century cars and chemistry.
Aerospace and electronics.
This shouldn't be that hard this isn't a crazy idea.
This is what we see every day.
I mean after all how many of you have Blackberries?
So retro! Did you come here on a fixie? I bet you did.
This is a basic idea: that when a product comes out
there's tremendous opportunities for profits.
It grows over time, and then as it becomes
a mature industry: it falls.
And this isn't true just of particular
products like Blackberries but entire industries.
So over time as the technology becomes well known,
it becomes a commodity industry.
This is just normal ways of thinking.
Now these leading sectors are very important.
Because first of all I think it should be obvious
that aerospace is not obvious. That most of us
cannot just walk outside and be like
"Oh, let's build a plane. Cool." It's actually super hard.
It's very hard to build a railroad.
It's very hard to imagine an industry as
complicated as the electronics industry.
And so this transformation is not obvious.
What that next leading sector will be.
And yet, so far we have been able to figure out what it is.
Finding that new industry that allowed us to
bootstrap ourselves into the next level of growth.
But finding that next sector has not
been obvious in the past.
As it was not in the 1930s.
As it was not in the Great Depression.
When there's a failure to find that new leading sector,
when capital does not find its way into a sector that
can pull along millions and millions
and billions and billions of people
we have a depression.
When capital can't find that place to earn that profit
And that's what happened in the 1930s.
If you look closely at the industries of the 1930s
after the initial crisis:
the crash of the stock market in 29
followed by a crash in the housing market
a couple years later, all the cutting-edge industries
like electronics and  aerospace
they were fine within 6 months.
But they were this big. They were this big.
More people in the US worked in candy manufacturing
than in airplanes in the 01930s.
And all the big places where we invested all our capital
all our biggest employers--like cars--just wasted away.
This stagnation was a crisis of the failure
of capital to get into these new industries.
Where is capital in America?
In the 01930s it was in banks.
And capitalists like Amadeo Giannini
the founder of Bank of America,
I want you to notice that he is not skiing.
He is not smiling. He's a very nervous Italian guy.
He does not know what to do with all his money.
This is a letter (that) more than any graph
I think reveals this anxiety. This is a letter
from the Citibank Archives
between the head of Citibank (then known
as National City Bank) and the Bank of America.
"My dear A.P., I want to give you a short report
of conditions here, and put before you
the City Company situation.
Our excess reserves are very big.
It's almost impossible to find any use for money
in credits that we are willing to take,
and the rates are terribly low."
Too much capital. Nowhere to put it.
Even though millions are out of work.
And these new industries that we now know
are great investments.
That are capable of producing millions of jobs
don't have capital to grow.
I want you to think about that